Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are taking you to the summit.
We're taking you to the peak.
We're giving you a peek behind the scenes
at the YouTube Summit.
This is an invitation-only event that
usually happens annually,
depending on what's happening with like
global medical pandemic crises.
I think it came to a stop,
but they gave us an invitation this year.
Are we authorized to talk about this?
And we went.
I think we are not-
We are never gonna be invited again.
I think we're not
supposed to talk about it,
but the stuff that we're gonna talk about-
We're not gonna,
we're not gonna talk about anything
that we shouldn't talk about.
We're just gonna kind of relay our-
I'm gonna talk about
everything that I experienced.
And I want you to hear about it.
Cuz you know what,
these are like the YouTubery
of YouTubest of the YouTube.
There's probably some sort
of threshold of people they
invite cuz they only
have a certain capacity
for people to come to this thing,
and it's probably like,
I don't know,
you've gotta really be
successful on YouTube.
I mean-
There's some criteria that
they didn't tell us about,
but I'm glad we were invited.
Everyone there is succeeding on YouTube.
Everybody that we talked to there that we,
if I didn't know them
or if I did know them,
it turns out that they're all-
Successful on YouTube.
Catastrophically popular.
Catastrophic probably
isn't the right word.
I think it was different stages.
It was interesting and that's
one of the things that,
the reason I was saying,
hey, why don't we talk
about this on the podcast,
is because I find myself
like I'm catching up
with friends and it's
one of the first things
that comes to mind-
Right.
Because it's an interesting
thing that we went to.
It's a weird event.
And we met some interesting people.
And it's just one of those things that
happens just because of
the job that we have-
Yeah.
An experience that we only can have
because of this weird
career that we have chosen
and the fact that this career
has gone unexpectedly well.
And there's not another event
that we can attend as creators
that's like this because,
I mean this may be the seventh
year that they've done it.
And again, during the
pandemic for two years,
they didn't do it,
but like seven years
ago was the first one,
which we were invited to that one.
I think we've always been invited,
but we've only been able to
go to like the very first one.
We wanted to go to some other ones-
We're busy men, Link.
And then this is, we're like we finally,
we're able to with our
schedule say we could do it
because it was in Palm Springs.
But the way that they do it-
Oh, can you say that?
I just did, man.
I don't know if you can
even say that, where it was.
I think we're gonna bleep that out.
Palm Springs.
Nope, another bleep.
Oh, that one they had the bleep out
and put a black spot over your face.
Ah, that was two long beeps.
Before we talk about that-
But hold on, what I was trying to say-
Okay, you were trying to say something-
Was the thing that's weird about it
and different about it
is they don't let you bring your people.
You know?
Whenever you become a successful creator,
you surround yourself with people.
You have agents, you have managers,
you have all types of people
doing all types of things.
Representation.
Talk to the people, talk to my hand,
you know, kind of a thing.
None of that.
So it's,
you know as a creator
you're going into this space
where the only people
who aren't creators are,
well, you're YouTube employees.
And it turns out that they're
gonna really want to talk to
you about making shorts.
Which I guess we can
talk about that later.
But my point is,
you can rub shoulders with other creators,
get to know them,
and there's less pretense
because you don't,
there's not a lot of people
at the party, so to speak,
who want something from you.
Once you get traction on the internet
and you start to go to like
business thrown parties-
Mixed company.
You go to mixers.
There's some creators there,
but then there's everybody
else who's trying to get in on
that action and have these conversations
that they want something from you.
They want you to be involved in something.
They wanna go into business with you.
They have business cards.
We don't carry business cards.
So YouTube has done a good
job of creating a space where
you can just talk to other creators
and you know that there's
much less pretense.
When you talk to other creators,
they're asking us questions,
we're asking them questions.
It's a lot more sincere.
And you don't really
have to think as much,
what do they get out of this conversation?
Why am I bored to tears
and I can't get out of this
conversation after being
in it for 40 minutes?
I mean there are some
creators that I'll see
at a event like this and
like we've got an ongoing
conversation about something
that isn't even related to our
careers at all that we kind of pick up
and keep talking about.
Like, I'm, you know,
I'm not gonna talk that's
just private stuff.
But like it's just cool to
have friends in the space
to kind of like catch up and-
Commiserate.
Yeah, well and just like
connect with somebody who,
there's a select group of people
in the world who understand
what the job that we're trying to do.
Firsthand.
You know, firsthand.
And it's just, it's cool
to get to talk to em
cuz we're not part of the scene.
Like we don't hang out
with a bunch of YouTubers.
Nope.
There's a bunch of YouTubers in LA,
we don't hang out with them
because just be honest,
we don't hang out with many people at all-
Nope.
Because we do a lot of working
and a lot of familying.
And I love it that way.
So we're gonna talk a lot about that,
but I did wanna ask you a question.
I wanted to catch up with you
because I did see that Dr. Emily Morse,
sex spurt,
who we had on the show,
if you do recall during
our episode of Sextember,
when we talked to her and maybe
mentioned some contraptions
that go into certain places on your body.
I was the first to break the seal on that.
Well she explained that
she had some things
that she may send us.
And I will say that we
received those things
and you know what,
I feel like I'm not even
gonna describe what it is
because if you wanna go
listen to Sextember you can-
Right.
And I don't necessarily wanna make this-
I don't wanna put a disclaimer on this.
I don't wanna have to
put a disclaimer on this,
but I just wanna ask you,
we received some things
and have you received,
have you fully received the
thing that you received yet?
Thank you for asking.
Because I have.
I-
That night.
That night I tested it out.
I'm different than you.
I was like, this needs to be for-
It was sitting over there on
the counter in my bedroom.
This has to be for a special occasion.
My wife was out of town.
I just felt like a droid
just trying on a new part.
Listen,
I've set an appointment to try it out.
Oh, with a doctor?
I need to have proper supervision.
I'm serious dude.
Why are you laughing?
You mean that you have set a time with you
and your wife to be like,
we're gonna try this.
Yeah.
I haven't told her that yet.
Did you put it on the calendar?
Yeah.
Is it on our shared calendar?
It's not on your blank wrist
that you keep looking at.
This is an expression man.
It's not the fifties.
Here's the thing,
all expressions started with a reality.
So when I look at my watch as a joke,
it's not that I think
that I have a watch on,
I'm doing a time joke.
It's a joke.
It's so funny.
This is why you need to watch,
watch Ear Biscuits as long
as well as listen to it.
Well it comes out on video later.
I just can't wait.
It came right out cuz I use Loop.
So I will,
believe that I will have-
She sent lube as well.
A report.
We don't have to bleep lube, do we?
Just don't keep saying it.
Lube can be like getting
an oil change man.
Jiffy Lube, you don't have to bleep that.
Not a sponsor.
Yeah Christy and I are going on a getaway
and I'm bringing it.
Taking out on a getaway.
Okay, all right.
That's probably a good idea.
I will let you know when I tried it.
Take some video, FaceTime.
So yeah, I'll get back to you on that.
Okay, all right.
Emphasis on the back.
I'm glad we could catch up about that.
I'm feeling a little sluggish.
We just took a little trip across town.
I don't know when this is coming out.
We don't do those a lot.
Speaking of YouTubers,
got to hang out with our boys
Ryan and Shane over at Watcher
cuz we're doing, they're
all on our channel,
we're on their channel.
I don't, yeah, that doesn't,
I don't think it comes
out until November though.
So get ready for that.
Yeah, there's a little preview.
Set yourself an appointment,
you know what I'm saying?
Some things you gotta work up to.
You just can't go home that night
and just watch us on that channel.
You gotta build up to it.
Right.
You gotta loosen up.
You gotta be relaxed.
You gotta be in the right frame of mind.
It depends on your personality.
But I will say that while we
were on the other side of town,
I remembered that, and Jenna was with us,
so it was three of us,
I remembered a place that
Josh had recommended.
Now Josh of course is-
He's a foodie.
One of the culinary experts around here.
He's a mythical chef, which
means a fake chef, I guess.
No, he's very much a real chef.
He's real.
And he has never led me wrong-
Mm-hmm.
When it comes to a
recommendation in this town
that I love this town,
one of the many reasons is all the food.
Crawling with food.
And so I just wanted to say
I felt like I built that up
because Josh built it up for me.
You may remember that
episode of what's the show
that we make Good Mythical
Morning where we had corn smut,
which is essentially a
fungus that grows on corn
and it has like a truffle like flavor
and there's a different name for it,
I can't remember the name of it,
but corn smut is sort of
the rough slang name for it.
And this place,
the chef at this what
essentially is a taco stand
where all the seating is outside-
It's called Bees.
B, double E, S.
Yup.
Just like a flying bee.
Tacos.
Taqueria.
Is that how you say that word?
Yup.
Am I saying that right?
And so this place they do
the corn smut and then,
what is the word-
Did I eat corn smut?
No.
So they don't do,
the chef does essentially
like a coursed out dinner.
I don't know if he still does this,
but he does like a coursed
out dinner of that's
a corn smut like tasting,
and he incorporates it into all the tacos.
But he only does like one
a day certain days of the
week or something.
You has to call away ahead of time.
I like Jesse and I went down
there one time cuz on Josh's
recommendation and we were
gonna have the corn smut thing.
And he was like,
oh only that's one table a night
and you have to call like
a month ahead of time.
He goes, now that I'm talking about it,
it may be longer than that.
But anyway I wanted to make
sure y'all got a taste of these
tacos which I just think that they're like
the best tacos in town I mean-
They were really good tacos.
I feel a little weighed down though,
because you stopped
short on your third taco
and I wasn't prepared for another taco.
You ate it.
Stop short.
My mind, one part of my brain said,
just have a bite and then my
body said, eat the whole taco.
And I did.
I noticed that you started like,
I took a couple bites and then I was like,
this is my third taco, who am I fooling?
I'm not going here.
I'm done.
I'm listening to my body.
And then I said would you
like the rest of my taco?
Oh you listening to your body
tells you to stop eating.
Yeah.
I'm body saying the opposite
of what my body said.
It's called being full.
And then-
My body's like, bring it.
So I give it to you and I
noticed that you started eating
off of the other side.
Cuz that was my way of
saying I'm not going to eat
all the way through the taco
til I get to Links border.
Right, where my mouth had been.
I'm creating a Rhett border
on this side of the taco.
So I thought,
I just assumed that you
were gonna leave a sliver.
Stop.
Between-
I assumed-
My last bite and your last bite.
I assumed it as well,
this is how my brain was.
I actually made it easier for you to stop
because there was a border.
And even if it was just a sliver,
that would've been a little something.
But then I look back a
lightning clap later-
It's all gone.
And it was gone.
I guess it's the thunder that claps,
but you know what I mean?
And Jenna had essentially
done the same thing as you,
but she had created a Jenna
border on all three tacos
and had used discipline
to stop on all her tacos.
And at this point-
Oh, really?
My body said finish Jenna's tacos too.
I thought you were, I was like-
Did you do that?
No, no, cuz my brain at that
point kicked in and said,
you do not need to do that.
You've got a podcast to make.
But I'm still-
You don't seem weighed down.
I'm a little sluggish.
I mean little sluggish
after that you know,
after I had dealt with Dr. Emily's gift
and had an extra half taco.
I gotta tell you, I mean I was,
there was a little cup of beans
and I think that hurt me cuz like
I was in pain all the way home.
I didn't wanna tell you guys,
but like I was in a lot of pain.
That wouldn't be from,
I don't think you can beans are
gonna have a gassiest effect
within literally within minutes.
Yeah, they do though.
It was 20 minutes.
I don't know.
We need to Google that.
I feel better now.
I'll put it to you that way.
All right, here we go.
So let's talk about Palm Springs.
The top secret.
Well, before we do that-
Invitation only.
Let's talk, we got-
YouTube event.
Let's talk quickly about the camping trip
that we went on with Stevie.
It finally happened.
We joked about it forever.
Quite a buildup.
Joke became a reality.
We actually did it.
We created multiple videos
of our camping experience.
We filmed it all.
Ooh it was quite the camping trip.
We had a good time.
I think it's gonna translate
into your viewing experience.
We're gonna release it
on the Mythical Society
because if when you pay
for the Mythical Society,
you get what you pay for or more.
So it's a win-win.
You know.
So we're putting this over there.
How are we doing it?
We're available first,
second, and third degree.
That's generous.
This came out on Friday.
You can so go, just go,
basically just go over to
mythicalsociety.com,
become a member if you aren't one,
and watch the camping trip videos.
We had a good time.
I'm not gonna say things got naughty,
cuz they didn't.
I didn't bring any of my toys.
But everything was good.
Had a blast.
Join in the fun.
mythicalsociety.com.
Okay.
How did you, what was
your disposition entering
into the YouTube Creator Summit?
Because going in as what
you might call an OG-
Yup.
You're going in as one of the guys
that's been doing this a very long time.
Yeah, there weren't that
many people who were there
at the first one seven years ago.
And I know Hank was there.
Hank Green.
Yeah.
There's a few other people.
I just can't remember em all.
My mindset was,
I was looking forward to it,
I didn't have to get on a plane.
We just drove to Palm Springs,
which it's not a great drive.
I mean you come outta LA
and you think you can go
to Palm Springs and it's
like an hour and a half.
And then you Google it and
it says it can take anywhere
from two to four and a half
hours to get to Palm Springs.
Like there's just something
about the way that the traffic
flows out of LA at any time.
I'm talking about two
o'clock in the afternoon-
Going east.
On a Tuesday.
Going east out of town-
On a Tuesday in the
middle of the afternoon.
It's always crazy.
It could take over twice as long.
It could take four and a half hours.
I would say-
And that's happened to me before.
I would say going any direction
because I've gone south before,
like trying to get to San Diego
and then you don't leave
before noon on a Friday.
But we didn't have to get on a plane now.
Six hour drive or
something crazy like that
you could get caught up in.
I was pretty excited.
You know, I think I can
get in a mode to be social.
That's an understatement.
But you know, so it's like, I kind of,
I feel like I can turn
on being an extrovert.
There was a certain point in the,
let's see so it was,
we got there that afternoon,
there was a mixer that night.
You stay that night and
it's all the next day
and then another night,
and then the next day it's like a half day
worth of programming.
So we had two nights,
one full day and then a half day.
So you can-
So at a certain point
I had to go to my room
for like an hour during the
day and like take a nap,
but other than that I was in like,
I was in what you might call Link mode.
I wouldn't call it an on switch.
I would call it the dial
broke and the dial came off.
You call this an on and off?
Well-
I consider it an on.
Well listen-
And then the dial is broken.
I, here's what I did.
You know, I considered you,
which meant that,
I was like, you know what,
whenever we enter into like a
mixer or something like that,
I'm gonna go this way,
you can go that way?
You know?
I just feel like I can give
you a little space, you know?
Cuz I mean it,
yeah, definitely one of
the people that we met
that I hit it off with,
the Long Snapper,
we'll talk more about later.
Uh-huh.
We were hanging out
and then like the next morning
we were hanging out again at breakfast,
and in the middle of our
conversation at breakfast,
he said are you always like this?
And I like took it as a compliment.
Cuz he kind of had this smile on his face.
He was like are you always like this?
And I'm like-
And did you say, what do you mean by this?
I said what you see is what you get.
That's what I said.
I didn't want to explain
well you know what,
I don't get out much and
I don't make new friends.
And this is a fun environment.
Hold on, that's how you would explain it.
I don't get out much
and I don't really meet people very often.
I can't sustain this level of energy
if we had like an ongoing friendship,
but like over the course
of like a retreat,
I'm bringing my energetic,
I'm bringing my enthusiasm to this space
because I legitimately was
excited about connecting
with people who spoke our language.
And they were interested in me,
I was interested in them.
And-
But I think people-
It was fun.
I think people might be surprised.
And incidentally,
when we got to the first
sort of gathering that night,
and you were like, you went
to the bathroom immediately,
and I was like-
You always go to the bathroom first.
Well I didn't even-
Cuz you can pee and you
can look in the mirror.
Okay.
I don't like showing up at
a place and walking around
and talking to like five people
and then having to pee and
then looking in the mirror
and realizing that there's
something fundamentally
wrong with my face.
Well, that might not be a,
you can't change that though.
What do you mean?
No I mean,
like it's not,
I guess unfundamentally,
something that is easily preventable,
but no one had the heart to tell me
because I was sparing you,
you would've told me.
But like, you know-
But when you made that decision,
I mean we didn't talk about it,
but I do think that for the most part-
You're saying when I decided
to go to the bathroom?
I just went into the party
and just started talking to people.
Because I do think that,
well because you said you
framed it at the beginning
as if you were like I'm
gonna to go over here,
but I was-
Oh yeah, we didn't discuss this.
That was my frame of mind as well.
Not just because I knew you
were gonna be in Link mode
and there's only so much room for that,
which is true,
but it was more like,
we get a lot more out of this experience-
Right, right.
Wen we divide and have multiple
conversations with people
and get to know more people.
Yeah, and then we come back
together and we trade notes
and sometimes you'll have
an interaction with somebody
a little bit later than me
and then they will realize
that they've had the exact same
conversation with both of
us only separated by time
because we're us.
Maybe that's not the case though.
I think that's less
and less than the case.
Well, okay, then let's talk about we can,
one of the things we can talk about
is what do we talk to people about,
and then see if we were giving
people the same experience.
Like I talked to this one couple who
they were asking me,
they knew I had kids,
they don't have kids.
And they asked me should we have kids?
And I'm like don't put
me in this position.
This is like the most fundamental,
talk about fundamental question
that you can ask a person,
this is your entire life trajectory.
You're putting it in my hands.
Like I'm not,
I can't tell you whether you
should have children or not.
I have a very interesting
POV on this conversation.
And so I'm like, listen,
and they were like, well, I mean, just
tell us your perspective.
I was like, oh, I have the answer.
I'm just not gonna tell you,
because I don't want to be the one
who told you what you
should do and then you do it
and then your life is either
amazing or screwed up.
I mean it's like, don't put this on me.
And I think that's when you
walked up and I was like,
you know what, you take it from here.
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
And so-
So what did you tell them?
They asked.
So here, this is exactly what happened.
So they said we're
gonna ask you a question
that we just asked Link.
And then they ask the
question should we have kids?
And the first thing I said
is, well what did Link say?
And then I think the exact words
were he got very belligerent.
Yeah, yeah, don't put me in that position.
Like that's what I'm talking about.
The dial being broken.
You're gonna shirk your
responsibility on me.
Is being interpreted.
If you're asking me if
you should have children,
then no, no you shouldn't.
Don't and I mean we
barely know each other.
I think the question
that they were asking,
and this is how I answered the question,
was you have kids,
what is your perspective on having kids
and what would you say
to someone of our age
who is considering it?
So I just asked after I
asked them what did Link say
just because I wanted to
see what they would say
and hoping for an answer
like the one I got.
They used the word belligerent?
Yeah.
That's a little harsh.
I said, okay well,
I said something like what do you value?
You know?
Like what is it that
you think you're after?
Okay.
With considering children and like,
what do you like about
your life right now?
Because I was like,
you asked me this question.
I'm a guy who comes from a
very particular background
where I was on a very particular plan
where having children very
soon into a very young marriage
was part of the formula.
It was not a decision.
It wasn't even a decision.
Right.
And now here's all the
benefits I have of being a 44
now 45 probably by the time
you hear this year old man
with an adult child and a teenage child.
And now I'm getting,
I'm still young and I'm getting
ready to have some fun man.
You know the people we were
talking to were younger than us,
but older than we were when
we decided to have kids.
And so then they were like,
well we feel like we've kind
of like traveled everywhere
that we want to travel.
We're actually kind of looking
to sort of settle down.
I was like, well that's a,
I'm not saying you should have kids,
but the fact that you're
thinking about settling down
sometimes growing a family
is part of that process.
So that's the way I
interacted with the question.
I think that we gave em
the old one two punch.
One two punch, baby.
See I let em know that like,
this is not something to take lightly.
Yeah, yeah.
You really set it up for me.
I really set it up.
Yeah.
For you.
I'm glad I walked up.
I was messing with them,
But I also felt like,
because I didn't know them,
it wasn't like the first time we ever met,
what's wrong with this
guy who I've never met?
Like I've had many endearing
interactions with this couple.
Yeah like right before the pandemic,
I saw him at a noodle shop.
That was the first thing we talked about.
Mm.
And that's why they-
They should ask you should
we have these noodles?
It was me, Christie, and Lando.
So they met Lando.
And so they kind of knew-
They saw what the family looks like.
Well they saw part of it.
I got two other whole
children that weren't there.
They saw enough.
Aaw enough to draw a conclusion.
So it wasn't like,
who's this crazy person?
Like, are you always like this?
They didn't ask me that.
Yeah, that was the
person you had just met.
Yeah, yeah.
Story's not really adding up here.
I mean, listen, I knew these guys,
unlike the other people that I went up to
that I didn't know.
Well, my approach with people was,
well first of all,
I gotta say I'm sure you
experienced the same thing.
There's always a question
when you enter an environment
like this and of course there's the people
that we know and we have been
friends with for some time
and have been in this
business for a long time
and they were pretty
well represented there,
like the Hank Greens of the world.
Not to say that Hank Green
is a genre of person,
but you know what I'm saying,
people who've been on this
platform for a long time.
Yeah, he is one of a kind.
Every time I see Hank, I'm
like you are such a genre.
But to have the people that
I did not recognize come up
to me and say hey, I've been
watching you since I was eight.
I literally had a person say that,
I've been watching you
since I was eight years old.
And then I had many others say,
I've been watching you
since middle school.
Right, and they're like, 18, 20, 22, 24.
But it was cool because you never know.
Like this is a big world that-
Right.
You don't have to get a license
to upload a YouTube video.
You don't have to pass a test.
You just start doing it.
So the-
Trust me,
The entry point is, point
of entry or whatever,
the barrier to entry is not existent.
So but the people who've gotten
to this place where they've
quickly grown a platform it
was just cool to be like,
hey they're coming up to me and
they're asking me questions.
Like that was something that happened.
Lots of people asking questions like,
so like you're still making videos?
Like how are you still, how
are you still making videos?
How are you still relevant?
That hurts.
I heard you guys that
build a big business.
Like how did you do that?
So I would enter into
that kind of conversation,
But most of the time what
I was trying to do is just,
I mean, I didn't, I don't watch enough,
I don't watch very much YouTube.
Yeah.
And I definitely don't,
like most people that I
was meeting were new to me.
Their content was new to
me, completely new to me.
Oh yeah.
So I would always be like,
well tell me about your channel.
What do you do?
What's your content?
Yeah, that's not what I do.
What I did was,
so I was sitting down at another time
and there was this like young guy,
I would say, I don't know,
21, could have been younger.
And I had seen his content
and I said a little bit of it
and I said you know what,
I love your content.
You're like doing the
lifestyle vlogging thing
like you and your girlfriend.
I just wanted to show him like,
I know what's up with you.
And he was like,
me and my girlfriend?
I was like, yeah, you and your,
well I was like, she's in
a lot of the thumbnails.
And he was like that's
me as a character I play.
Oh.
And I was like, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I've been watching real close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're doing great.
You're doing great there.
I mean, you are-
I think I'll stick with my method.
Yeah.
And then I ended up explaining,
I was like the truth of the matter is
I have watched your content,
but I'm getting you confused
with somebody else because-
Yeah.
And I was explaining the,
because he was a Mythical
Accelerator candidate.
You know what?
And I'm sitting there like
we're trying to invest-
Oh yeah, in you and your girlfriend.
We're trying to-
We're really excited
about you and your girl.
We're trying to invest in creators.
And like so there's people
who look at creators and say-
Maybe we should have stuck together.
This person is interesting.
You should check 'em out.
Do you want us to follow up?
And I'm like, I just look at the channel,
I look at stuff and I'm like-
Yeah, follow up.
You should write a book called
How to Dig a Hole Immediately
And Then Try To Get Yourself Out Of It
throughout this conversation.
It's fun dude.
It's uncanny, man.
It's fun.
Like you know,
there's a post pandemic
part of this that's like,
I've been cooped up.
Okay.
You know, kind of a thing that's like
you get back out there.
Are you saying this is
a long COVID symptom.
Hit switch, pull cart, you know?
Are you saying that you just, you're just-
Yeah, this is a long-
You're just excited.
I mean I'm suffering from my
own version of long COVID.
You gotta start conversations.
I don't get out much,
but I'm just in a sense it is
what you see is what you get.
Like I'm being very sincere.
I thought he and his
girlfriend made great content.
Yeah, they probably do.
He just is his girlfriend.
Right, I mean it's actually a compliment.
Some of the time.
He's so convincing.
And he was like yeah I've
been watching you guys
since Chia LinK.
And I was like, oh, okay yeah.
Maybe let's keep talking.
We can still make this work.
Have I screwed this up?
So the people that-
I don't like putting on airs.
I'm not-
I'm not saying you are.
I just, the only thing
I've said is that I say,
tell me about your content.
Yeah, that's fair.
That's how I start the conversation.
I'm not saying that's an air,
that's a fair question.
But the thing,
okay, so I wanna talk to you
about the people that I met
and the way that I learned their story
and then the way that I
ended up hyping them up
to other people at the Creator Summit.
So-
Okay.
I don't want to walk up to this guy,
I can't remember, young guy,
I think he's actually like 25 or so,
but I didn't, I thought
early twenties or whatever.
Yeah.
And so I'm like tell me your story.
What do you do?
And he is like, well, I
used to work at Coldstone.
Fair.
And I was like, whoa I'm not
interested in your resume.
I didn't ask you what you did before.
He's like no this is
pertinent information.
He was like I worked at Coldstone
and I put an iPhone like
right here under my chin,
giving you a POV of what
I was doing at Coldstone.
And of course at Coldstone,
if you haven't been to one,
if you're outside of America,
maybe you haven't been to one,
but this is basically like where
you're taking a ball of ice
cream and rolling it
around and mixing it up
with the ingredients on
like a piece of marble.
You're underselling it.
I mean they have two frozen
mallets and they have-
It's pretty awesome.
They artistically mush
the ice cream together
and they call em folds.
They fold the ice cream in with mix ins.
So he says I started doing this
and I was just doing these POV videos
and posting them to TikTok originally.
Yes.
And they were getting all these views.
People just love this content.
And I'm like, okay wow.
This is me in my mind.
I'm like, wow okay.
He says, then I started I
kind of talked to Coldstone,
maybe it was gonna become
something where I'm working
for Coldstone, am I
gonna work for Coldstone
as a guy who makes these videos?
Long story short is because
Coldstone is a typical
corporation with a bunch of
people who don't understand
how this stuff works involved,
they couldn't figure out
a way to work with him
in a way that made sense.
So what did he do?
He went and started
his own ice cream shop.
Wow.
In New York City.
Dang.
And here's what he does.
So first of all, his
name's Dylan, Dylan Lame'.
You probably-
That's cool.
If you know this content,
you know this content,
because the dude has got
millions of subscribers
and all kinds of views
and really the shorts.
On YouTube.
So eventually,
and a lot of creators there
at the summit were people
who had gotten initial traction on TikTok,
and then because of the
YouTube shorts program,
short vertical videos, 60 seconds or less,
they've gotten all this
traction on YouTube
and their subscriber
accounts that have gone up
really, really fast.
So these people have grown
faster on the platform in terms
of views and subscribers
than any previous generation
of any wave of YouTube,
way faster.
Like ridiculous.
10 of millions of views on each short,
maybe pushing a hundred
million views on a short.
Yeah and he's got some huge videos,
but he makes multiple videos a day.
So he opens up his ice cream
shop called Catching Ice Cream.
And it's basically a
gimmick ice cream shop
where this is where he makes his content.
He's still doing his POV videos,
but now he's got these balls
of ice cream that have stuff
on em or whatever and he throws
you the freaking ice cream
and you catch it in a bowl at
the place Catching Ice Cream.
What?
And so he's telling me the story-
What if you don't catch it?
They clean it up and they
give you another one.
He says-
What if you don't catch that one?
At that point it gets uncomfortable
and they begin to say,
okay listen, if you
don't catch it this time,
we're gonna kick you out.
I asked him these same two questions.
I never talked to this
guy, I never met him.
What happens if they miss it?
What happens if they miss it again?
And he was like, it doesn't happen.
I love your girlfriend in it.
And then he was like,
and sometimes you just
take it and you just put,
if they can't catch it,
you just put it in there.
And this is a young kid.
This is cool.
You know, he is in his twenties.
I love his spirit.
He has crazy success.
He's got this ice cream shop in Manhattan.
They just literally opened
just a couple months ago.
So it's just trying to
just manage all this.
He opened an ice cream shop
to create YouTube shorts
and TikTok content.
That was the means to the-
He's basically taking short form traction
through TikTok and YouTube shorts
and immediately translating it into
a brick and mortar business,
which happened at such a scale.
I mean, it's such a quick timeline.
Anyway, so I'm talking to him-
Did he throw anything in your
mouth while you're talking?
I requested him to throw at that point
for the rest of the time there,
I would go and just point at food
and he would throw it in my mouth.
That's how I consumed all the food
for the rest of the weekend.
Okay, okay, cool.
So I'm talking to-
Don't believe it.
A night later I'm gonna, I wanna,
I'm sure you got people
you wanna talk about too.
I'm gonna finish the Dylan story
cuz there's more people I'll come back to.
So I had that conversation with him.
The next night I get into a
conversation with somebody
who's been on the platform
for nearly as long as us,
Linus Tech Tips.
And so if you know, if you care about
tech stuff and you watch YouTube videos,
you already know about Linus Tech Tips.
Huge channel, huge business.
He's based in?
Vancouver.
So in lots of things
in common with the way
that he's built his business
and of a large business,
a lot of employees.
And so we had long conversation
just about what it's
like to be a creator
who started this channel
and all of a sudden you're
running this media company.
Very cool conversation.
Absolutely.
Seven years ago at the
first YouTube Summit,
we weren't talking to
anybody who had 70 employees
like I believe he has.
Yeah, something like that.
And now we have 130.
It's like this strange phenomenon
that we've been able to
ride these waves, so like
to be able to connect was,
and yeah I was in the
beginning of that conversation.
Well and so I'm talking to him,
we're getting to know each
other as guys who are aware of
one another but have never
actually met and connected.
Yeah.
Dylan, ice cream man,
comes into the conversation
and I was like,
I thought if Linus didn't know about him,
I was like, Hey, tell him,
you know this guy. He's like, No.
I said, Tell him your story man.
Oh, you're a matchmaker,
you're a connector.
He was like, well I make ice cream.
I said, no, no man,
start from the Coldstone.
Yeah baby.
I said, tell it like you told it to me.
That's right.
And he's telling it and
then I'm literally like-
Crying?
Like his dad.
Oh.
Because I'm like, hey
man, what do you tell me?
An ice cream shop. What do you do?
What do you do when somebody drops it?
I'm hyping him up man.
Yeah.
Cuz he's too humble.
He was just being too humble about it.
I was like, dude,
You gotta be full of yourself
to make it on YouTube.
You worked at Coldstone
and now you own your own
ice cream shop in Manhattan
cuz you can freaking
film yourself doing it.
During that same conversation,
another guy-
Crowd formed?
Enters again, if you know, you know,
because these guys are so popular.
Melod.
Okay?
Very similar story.
This guy, his parents own a Subway.
He's doing the same thing.
He's a sandwich artist filming
himself making sandwiches.
Are they holding the
phone between their chin
and their collar bone?
Like no.
Or do they have a harmonica mount?
They did that in the early days,
but since then they
have some sort of mount,
cuz that would be crazy.
And this is what they do,
they film themselves doing something
and then they do a voiceover,
very calm voiceover-
Mm-hmm.
That often is completely
unrelated to the thing
that they're making.
It's this kind of like break
your brain a little bit
if you're Gen M millennial,
zinneal what we are.
Because this is, again, I'm
sounding like an old man,
but cuz it, to me, it's weird, right?
You can't break me.
You're showing me something-
Can't break my soul.
And you're answering a
question that's unrelated.
Yeah.
And this is what the kids want, man.
Now sometimes it'll be like,
what's the craziest sandwich
that anybody ever asked for?
It was meatballs and tuna
and he's making the meatballs and tuna
and then he turns the camera on himself
and he eats it at the end.
Oh, he okay so he does eat it.
So this guy owns, I mean this guy,
this guy's parents own a Subway,
I think they probably still do.
He's still doing the sandwich thing,
but now he's expanded his content
and he was one of the
people that was like,
I've been watching you
since I was seven years old
and he is still doing this stuff.
And then now he's doing
something with Jimmy,
with Mr. Beast.
He's got some, he's like eating
Mr. Beast burgers on his-
But again, it was one
of those things that-
It's cool man.
We get so in the weeds necessarily
with what we are doing,
what we're trying to accomplish,
and also we're just running a business,
it just takes time.
Yeah, it was nice to pull our heads
out of each other's asses.
And then talking to these,
for lack of a better word,
kids who are making this content
with an iPhone strapped
onto a thing on their bodies
doing these POV content and
they've been watching us
since they were kids and
they're doing this stuff
that is so like, yeah,
we're doing food content,
but there's two dudes
at a desk trying things
and making videos that
are 15 to 20 minutes long
and we're doing what we do
and we're not gonna change
what we do to any great degree.
I could probably different
fold a phone between my chin.
I mean I can try right now.
But those kinds of stories.
Well-
Like that.
The camera's, you'd be filming your goozel
cuz the camera's the wrong way.
Can you see me making an ice cream?
Yeah, I think there are-
Can you see me?
Can you see me making a sandwich?
I think that-
This is hard, man.
You're shaky hands would disqualify you
from doing that kind of content.
But it was inspiring.
It's inspiring to hear like, oh man,
this is the only on the internet.
Only because of the
internet and only because of
social media platforms like YouTube
can this kind of thing
happen where you just,
and here's the thing I
wanna be very clear about.
Be clear.
I don't look at this stuff
and get annoyed or angry or-
I love it.
Or have this like what, this is dumb.
He's just making sandwiches.
To me I'm like he's
just making sandwiches-
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Yeah, it's cool.
And and he's getting
this kind of traction.
I love it.
Because he's doing more than that
and he's got this POV, not just the POV.
It's deceptively brilliant.
Yeah.
Because it's-
They've created a genre of content.
They've created a new genre
that I go home that night
and I'm at a birthday party
that I've taken Shepherd to
and I'm having dinner with
the parents of this kid and
their 12 year old daughter
is there and I'm telling
them about my experience
and I'm telling them exactly
what I've just been telling you.
This guy, this ice cream guy.
And then the 12 year old girl
who's completely consumed
by her phone looks up
and says, you met Dylan.
And I was like, yeah and I
was like, and I met Melod.
She goes you met Melod?
And I go through the people that I met
and who were making the short form stuff
and it's like this is what she's watching.
I love it.
I can't say it enough, I love it.
It is inspiring.
Meanwhile, I'm at the
other end of the party
with the group of people
that I'm talking to
and I'm like I'm gonna sext my wife.
And they're like what?
I'm like see that guy
over there serving pasta
next to a cheese wheel,
there was a freaking cheese
wheel that he was scraping
using in a hot spoon and scraping
cheese out of this cheese
wheel and putting it on pasta.
And I'm like, here take my phone,
take a picture of me
behind this cheese wheel.
And like, Christy loves cheese.
And she loves you.
So take my picture.
So I texted Christy and I said,
can I sext you?
Now you know what I'm sorry to say
I've never sexted my wife.
That's just not something
we've ever tried.
You know?
I'm sure you have.
Hey, I'm Rhett, I have.
I've been sitting on this egg for a while,
it's time to hatch it.
Well I sext my wife all the time.
This isn't about you right now.
Well, you made it about me.
I haven't sexted my wife.
I've done other things with the phone.
Okay, great.
And I don't mean I put it in things.
I'm not saying-
You put it below your
chin and you just get,
that's not a good angle for you.
I'm trying to create a new genre.
Top down video.
So anyway, she doesn't reply and I'm like,
well take the picture.
So I get back in front, behind,
I asked the guy, I was like,
do you mind if I take your spoon
and stand next to the cheese wheel?
And the first picture I took
was like more of like a-
Hold on, you took the chef's spoon?
He was for it.
Well-
Turns out they were taking pictures of me
talking to the guy.
So you can see that I'm getting consent
in the pictures that I'm now showing.
And then he moved.
I had to explain to him,
I don't want you in the picture
cuz he turned and started
smiling at the camera.
And I was like, I don't this, I need to,
I'm trying to sext my wife,
I don't want you in the photo,
can you just stand over here?
And then I just stood in
front of the cheese wheel
and at first I was like, ugh.
Like I was just like, I don't know,
spluggling on the cheese wheel.
I don't know.
I just kind of go,
you know, I was at a party.
Yeah you were.
And then after that all of
my friends got in the picture
and we're taking pictures.
All your friends?
All my friends at the
party that I was making.
All the people that you just met?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were having a good time
and they were loving it.
They were like, this is so crazy.
I'm taking pictures that
Link's gonna send to his wife.
And then Christie never got back to me.
Yeah, right.
That night.
And then-
Was she asleep?
She was asleep.
Okay.
So then I actually I
didn't send the picture
cuz I was waiting for her to say,
yes I would like for you to sext me
or whatever she was gonna say.
And then when I woke up the next morning,
she had said something I think,
but it wasn't,
I can't remember,
it wasn't related.
So then I was like,
oh no, no, no, this is what happened,
when I got back to my hotel room
and I'm like sitting
there about to go to bed
and like Christie had
texted me by that point
and I hadn't seen her response.
So then I didn't,
and then I knew that she
was like I'm going to bed.
So I knew by the time I got
to my room she was asleep
so that when she got my sext
it would be in the morning.
So I was like I don't wanna
send the one where my eyes
are rolled back in my head.
I'm gonna send one that just
kind of looks like I'm a normal
guy in front of a cheese wheel.
It's more of a morning cheese sext.
I thought you guys like to
have morning sex though.
Yeah, I just didn't feel
like that's the type of thing
she wanted to wake up to.
So I sent her the other one.
Okay.
The good thing is she
knew that like even though
I was in party mode and making friends,
that I was thinking about her.
Yup.
And then the next morning
everybody was asking like,
what did she say?
What did she do?
And I told them what I told you
and it was kind of like
an anticlimactic story.
She didn't respond.
Yeah, she thought it was-
She was asleep.
She said very sexy.
Oh, she did eventually.
So she's playing along.
Okay.
Very sexy is what she said.
I did see that cheese wheel and I,
cuz what the guy was doing,
which again-
I didn't eat any of it though.
Yeah well this is-
Did you eat some of it?
This is the difference between me and you?
I saw a guy putting risotto
into a cheese wheel of Parmesan,
mixing it into the Parmesan
and then putting like
truffles on top of it.
And I didn't think about my wife,
I thought about the risotto
and I wanted to eat it,
and so I did.
Oh, okay.
I did think about my wife later,
but in that moment the cheese
wheel definitely took up
99.9% of my brain space.
That's fair.
And it was very good.
Of course I did take the
plate of risotto around
and people were like what are you eating?
Because it just looked like slop on a-
Yeah.
Just risotto on a plate at a party.
The only thing I,
they had like little, little
bites of chicken parm.
I had several.
And yeah,
and I would, I took one,
it would be one bowl
with a little fancy schmancy
little square of chicken parm.
And then so I took that one
and then I took more cuz I realize,
da, I realized,
past tense that like I hadn't been eating,
but I had been drinking.
So you can kind of start
to connect the dots.
So-
And I'm like, I need to eat.
So that's how you realized
that you need to eat.
I need to eat versus I'm
hungry and I go and eat.
It's like I don't wanna be belligerent.
I need to eat.
So then I had to like
recreate a full chicken parm
on one plate with like seven.
It was tough.
Well there was multiple foods.
There was a-
I didn't want-
I'll tell you all about the foods.
I didn't want any of the other foods.
Because I went around,
this is what I do when I get to a party.
I go to the bathroom
and you've already eaten everything once.
No, I go around and I
eat every single thing
because the foods get,
they change, they get cold.
I wanna know what I like,
I wanna know what I wanna go back for.
So I got the chicken parm.
They had an eggplant
parm on the other side.
They in between they
had a cup of charcuterie
that was like rolled
up stuff in like cheese
and salami and bread that
was like artisanally put
in this cup.
I got that twice.
They didn't even see that.
And then they had the risotto.
What else did they have?
And then they had some dessert
later on, which I also ate.
Yeah.
But lesson learned,
don't get a drink and eat at the same time
because then you've got,
you're holding a drink and
you've got a plate of food.
Yeah.
So you either drink first or eat first,
but don't do them at the same time.
Right.
And I had to learn that.
That was my like COVID leftover,
like forgetting how to go to a party.
Cuz I was sitting there talking to people
and I had a drink and then
I was looking for a table
and then the next thing you know,
so I put my drink down
on the table so I can eat
and a waiter comes and takes it.
And I was like-
One at a time.
Complete party fell.
But I think you're learning,
I mean if you're going to a party with us,
just stick with Rhett,
like he knows, he's like,
hey stand over here.
Like when we went to the
Rings of Power premiere,
I took Lily, you took Shepherd,
so the four of us are hanging around
and like Rhett comes up to me at like
when they start bringing
food out and he's like,
no, we had split up a little bit.
Yup.
Lily and I met some other people
and then all of a sudden
Rhett comes up to me
and he is like,
I figured out the best place
to stand to get the food,
they come out of this door right here.
No, no, this isn't something,
I figure this out at every party.
Yeah.
What door did the people
come out of with the food?
Come over here, I was like, thanks.
So at every party there
is a kitchen, right?
There is a room or a
kitchen in which the food
is being prepped and delivered from.
And that's the source.
And you set up and you don't wanna like
stand outside the kitchen.
Ah it seems like you
were standing outside,
you were stalking.
No, you wanna be the
first point that counts
as being at the party.
Yeah.
But is it the first
person that they run into
when they come out?
And here's what happens.
So the people who serve at these parties,
if you go to a premier or you
go to any of these parties
where there's people walking
around with plates of food.
The tray people.
Would you like a so and so homo?
Here's the thing about-
Would you like a so-and-so raw thing?
Now see already making
fun of these people,
but these people who have the trays,
they're working class people, right?
Come on now, don't make me the bad guy.
No, no, no.
Here's what I'm saying.
The only normal people at these parties,
and I'm talking about
typical like premiers
and Hollywood parties,
are the people serving the food.
Everyone else is a full
of themselves celebrity
like me and you.
True.
Okay?
And so, but here's what
you learn really quickly
is that the people serving the food
who are just people trying to make it.
They might be an actor
or struggling actor,
struggling artist, but
they're at this party.
Can't believe you're making it about this.
And no, seriously though,
what they want to do is they
don't like walking around
with this food and having these people
who are so full of themselves
turning noses up at the food.
Belligerent people.
These people, especially in LA,
they turn their noses up at food.
What Jessie and I,
cuz Jessie's just like me,
she wants to eat just like me.
Yeah.
That doesn't fit my diet.
She and I have figured out
that you make friends with
the tray people and then they're like,
every time I go to this
couple they say yes
to whatever I bring them.
And the big man drains it.
And so-
It's like they get their quote-
You become a magnet for food people.
Yeah.
And you can have like normal
conversations with them too,
because they're not putting on airs.
They're not there to impress.
They're there to work.
And I just find-
Come get me when your
bringing a slider out homie.
We went to one premier
and on the way out one of the tray guys
came up and he was like, hey,
I'm wearing Josh Shearer's pants.
That's Mythical chef Josh.
Yeah.
I was like, what?
He's like I'm Josh's brother-in-law.
And he had-
I have to be a tray
person and I needed pants.
He had just moved in.
I think he just moved
into town or whatever.
And he was like I had
to do this last minute
and I needed pants and
I'm wearing Josh's pants.
Those are the people that
you wanna talk to at a party.
The people with the food.
I thought you were gonna
say when we were leaving
the Rings of Power Premier,
and if you've watched Rings of Power,
in the first two episodes,
there's this guy who-
Oh yeah.
He comes down in a comet.
Okay?
And he lands and like this
precursor to a hobbit or
basically a migratory hobbit,
finds this naked dude.
Have you figured out who he is?
I haven't watched past it first.
Well by the time this comes out,
I think people will know,
but that's not really what this is about.
At this point in the story,
you don't know who this mysterious guy-
I think it's Gandolf.
It's not.
He fell from the sky and
he makes fire around him,
but nothing's hot to the touch
and he has amnesia-
And he's big.
But he's got a lot of hair
and he's a skinny white guy
with a big beard.
And as you were leaving the
premier when we had just watched
these first two episodes
and everybody's like,
who is this guy?
And it's like, it's not
Gandolf, shut up about that.
A woman comes up to you and says what?
She said did you,
you played the wizard in the show.
And I was like, thank you, yes.
She's like, you did great.
I was like, I appreciate that.
It's like he didn't have any lines.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Multiple people have texts
have tweeted at me saying-
He just laid down in the
fetal position and like-
Like people on the internet think it's me.
It's just a guy with
long hair and a beard.
I know there's not many of us.
There's not many of us.
Yeah, there's not many of you.
I mean, it might be Rhett.
It's gotta be Rhett.
I just didn't want to get
into the conversation of like,
well here's what I thought,
my brain was working really
quickly as I was leaving.
You were leaving first of all.
And I said to myself,
I don't wanna have this conversation,
but also if I say yes to this,
she gets to go home saying I met that guy.
I met that guy.
And so I thought I would give-
Still don't know who he is.
Yeah.
What character he plays.
The Stranger is what he's been called.
Two other guys I met, which again,
I'm back to the YouTube summit.
This is capturing the specificity man.
Another guy comes up again,
this guy had watched our
content since he was a kid.
And I was like what do you do?
And he says, I make dental content.
Dental Digest.
What?
And then he shows me his
channel and I immediately,
I'm like, oh boy,
like 10 million subscribers,
millions of views.
He showed you his channel on his phone?
Yeah.
This is like his version
of a business card.
I asked him what his channel was.
Is he working on people's mouths?
Is it tooth extraction?
Like I'm I'm not into that.
No, he is eating candy.
What?
Okay
First of all, he's in dental school.
He's gonna be a dentist, y'all.
Okay.
He eats candy and then
he brushes his teeth.
Yes.
He brushes his teeth.
So he's like these Mexican
candies versus my teeth
versus these-
It's basically like he a bunch
of candies from a particular
place or whatever and
do they cause cavities?
And the way that he finds this out,
again this is a dental student,
he brushes his teeth and then
he checks the pH of his teeth
of his mouth because the
pH of your mouth after you-
One of the reasons that
you get cavities apparently
is the pH changes that
take place when there's
all these sugar bugs.
Or not sugar bug, but sugar in your mouth.
Sugar bugs.
Well are those his words or yours?
I think he does use the word sugar bugs
because I think bacteria feed on sugar
when it's in your mouth
and so it does promote the
growth of unhealthy bacteria,
which think contributes,
I don't know how teeth work,
I didn't go to dental
school and I haven't watched
much Dental Digest other than what I was
shown in the moment.
But then-
But he brushes his teeth.
And he brushes his teeth.
So I talked to this guy
for quite some time.
He had a lot of questions
about growing a business
and I was-
And you had a lot of questions
about brushing your teeth.
I did.
I was like tell me about
those Mexican candies again.
So then literally 30 minutes
later I start talking
to another guy and I'm
like what do you do?
And he's like, I make dental content.
What?
And I was like, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Like we've already spoken.
There's not many people here, bro.
I just talked to another guy.
He said, oh yeah, I
know, Dental Digest, yes.
And this is a guy whose a little bit older
who is an orthodontist.
Again, these-
That's a different thing.
I know, but he is making like, he's also-
They should team up.
He's doing multiple things.
So this is-
Like the dental Power Rangers.
He's the ben-tist,
like I guess his name's Ben, the Bentist.
And so he's got his
content that's doing great,
doing great on shorts as well,
and he's got a whole different thing
where he's like answering questions.
He does a lot of different things
based on like quickly
looking at his channel.
But we got in a group of,
I don't know,
a hundred of these YouTubers
that have been invited to this event
because things are really
working on the platform for them,
two of them, 2% of them are dental guys.
And this content is just so popular.
That's crazy, man.
Like everybody's got teeth.
I mean most people.
Wow.
And then I, meanwhile,
I'm on the other side of the party,
like having my cheese wheels sext fun.
Yeah, man.
And I look over there at one of the people
I'm just talking to,
well I talked to the guy who
turned out to be the NFL long
snapper and then his wife
comes over and I was like,
I'll be damned if that's not an Olympian,
like that is, I know who that is,
I know who that is,
but I don't want to have
to ask her who she is
cuz I've seen her on a box of Wheaties.
But her name is on her
tag and it Shawn Johnson.
And I looked at her tag
and it said Shawn Johnson.
Well actually it said Shawn.
She's my new best friend
Jenna, are you freaking out?
I'm freaking out.
You wanta text her?
Yes.
Yeah, we can do that right now.
I did not say sext her, by the way.
I'm not gonna-
So it's Shawn East cuz
she married Andrew East.
And here's the thing-
I love both of them.
I am obsessed.
Hey guys, love you.
Here's the thing about-
We have some fun.
I'm a big fan of both of them.
Andrew in particular just-
They do family vlogging now.
Because he is a long snapper
and I am recently obsessed
with long snapping because
I listened to this episode
on some podcast where they were
talking about long snappers.
And again, if you're not
familiar with football,
this is the guy-
Don't say it with that tone.
This is the guy who bends
over and throws the ball
between his legs to like
a punter or somebody
who's about to hold the
ball to kick the ball.
And is he a short ways away?
He's a long ways away.
And it's this position that
was marginalized for many,
many years because it would
be like long snappers over the
years as the specialization
of different positions has
developed in the NFL-
It's kinda like a mirror of YouTube.
The importance of,
the long snapper is so important.
In fact, the joke is if you
hear a long snapper's name
during the game, that
means they screwed up,
because no one's gonna
be like the long snapper
did a great job tonight.
You only find,
if that's your job,
if you screw it up,
that's when people find out.
And the long snapper for the
Carolina Panthers is JJ Janssen
who he hasn't missed a
game in like 12 years.
I think he holds the current record
of any active player or something.
But I was just fascinated with
this position and I find out
Andrew was a long snapper for like-
I knew it.
10 years.
I knew you were gonna be enamored
with him once I passed him off to you,
but he came back to me the next morning
and asked me if I was always like this.
Right.
And now he didn't ask me
any questions like that,
but I asked him a lot of
questions about long snapping
and it was fascinating to get-
Do they get hit hard?
Because the reason why
you're snapping so long
is so that the punter
has more time to punt it.
You have to block so-
Then you block, you getting damaged.
Well first of all-
He had a pretty face.
You have to be,
well he's wearing a helmet.
You have to be-
Good for him.
If you're at any position
on the football field,
you're gonna be in shape and
you're gonna be relatively big,
I guess unless you're like the kicker.
Play for the Redskins.
So this-
Are they still called the Redskins?
Nope.
Well when he played they
were called the Redskins.
Yeah, I think it's called
the Washington Football Team
now and I don't know if
they've got a new name.
He played for multiple teams.
They don't have a mascot at all.
They were like, screw it,
we totally messed this up.
They're coming up with a new one.
We're not even going to mascot territory.
But after, as soon as you snap it,
you have to turn, you
have to block somebody,
but you're blocking somebody
who's really close to you
and then you're probably
just wrapped up with them
for the most of the play.
So you talked to him about this?
No, I just said, hey, no joke,
I'm not just saying this
because you're a long snapper,
but I'm kind of obsessed
with long snapping
ever since I heard about the
specialization of this position
and how they're now recruiting
kids in middle school.
Oh.
To become long snappers and
there's a couple of long
snapping coaches.
He was like yeah, so and so and so and so,
of course he knew who these people were.
And he's also a long snapping coach.
Oh, isn't this the thing that once,
like in the past year or two,
they change college regulations to where-
You can sponsor people.
You can sponsor people
and your idea was for us to
have a Mythical long snapper.
Yeah.
Well we-
Originally my initial idea
before I became obsessed
with long snappers was to just sponsor
like a weird position and then I find out
about long snappers.
That's it.
Let's do it.
And I don't necessarily know
if we need to sponsor one.
What if we sponsored-
All of them.
A bunch of longs snappers.
Yeah, let's really like-
Like the long snapper fund.
Right.
So Andrew, we're gonna
be talking to you about-
I talked to him about it.
I told him the idea.
I said, we've been talking about it.
There could be some-
Oh, you talked to him about that?
Yeah, yeah.
I said like, I feel like
there's content here,
you know, follow a long
snapper through the season
because it's such a specific position.
So listen, don't do
that show before we do.
If you see a long snapper show,
know that somebody stole our idea.
I don't think it can be done without us.
I mean we're obviously very
instrumental in whatever long
snapper content makes
this way on the internet.
No, but I do wanna do it.
I think we will be instrumental.
Well the thing that I
talked to him about was,
he told me this story that he was in,
when he was in a,
I think he was in a fraternity
or he went to a party
with some of his teammates
and he did not drink.
So he said, instead of drinking,
I'm gonna do the gallon challenge.
Milk?
Every time you drink alcohol,
I'm gonna drink milk
until I've drunk a whole gallon of milk
because they say you can't do that.
Right.
And I'm not condoning
for anyone to do that
cuz I don't know what
it does to your body,
but apparently at a certain point-
Milk does a body good.
I remember Jason Batson,
I told him this,
I was like when we were in
middle school one day he did,
he got all everybody's milk cartons
and like a gallon
equivalent of milk cartons.
And over that lunch period,
like people just started
hearing the murmurs of like,
Jason Batson's doing,
he's gonna drink a gallon of milk today.
He wasn't drinking a gallon of milk
cuz we didn't really understand the gallon
challenge at that point.
It was just Jason Batson's
gonna drink all the milk.
It was much miscalculated.
Much like the gallon challenge,
he just upchucked everywhere.
He was embarrassed.
Listen, I don't even think
he got into double digits.
Oh my gosh, he was bad.
It ended quick for him.
So he told me that, yeah,
he went to this party,
he went to this frat party
after he had been like
participating in this challenge,
and right when he got to the party,
he had to run to the bathroom.
And he said that like,
it was one of those things that's like
you know you're getting to the door
and it's just like you
just can't hold it anymore.
And just like as he flung the door open,
he just like vomited
everywhere in this house.
He's like you wonder how
it just gets everywhere.
Like how somebody just
totally destroys a bathroom.
It's like well I know
because I was that guy.
And I was like, and then how
long did you spend in there
just trying to clean it up.
He was like, no time at all.
Yeah, you gotta leave.
You gotta get outta there.
So then I told him my
story of like, when we were
in Park City and we met
our high school friend Eric
and I'm really developing
a reputation here.
I don't really drink that much,
but when I do, I really
have a story to tell.
I don't really drink that much,
but when I drink, I drink that much.
I just felt really sick the next day.
And we sat at this coffee shop
and I was embarrassed to tell
him that I was hung over
and like the sun was just
baking in and baking in.
And at least my recollection now
is that he ordered some food.
I think it was a egg, but
I don't know what it was.
It was a raw egg.
It was it like a sunny side up egg.
It made me sick to look at it.
And I ran to the bathroom and
the same thing happened to me.
I was like, dude, I know how you feel.
And then I just hurled
on every vertical surface
in that bathroom,
but then I just spent the next
15 to 20 minutes just like
pulling paper towels out
and just like mopping everything down.
And then I come back out
finally and you're like,
what happened?
I was like, no there was a line,
I don't remember what I said,
but I felt horrible.
The toilet was going very slow.
I actually felt better.
That's what I talked to him about.
So no real long snapping.
I asked him at one point if
he was ever in the Olympics.
He said, no.
And I just gave him a hard time.
I don't know if I-
He was like, I played in the NFL.
I was like, yeah but you
weren't on a Wheaties box.
I don't know if I've ever
met a gold medalist before.
She was also on a Cheerio's box.
And I was like, that's the ticket girl.
Also let me say that Andrew
and Sean were on our team,
we divided up into teams,
and our team,
first of all-
Scavenger hunt.
It was a scavenger hunt and
that involved some athletic
stuff and I looked at
our team and I was like,
we have a former NFL player
and an Olympian on our team.
If we don't win-
It's a problem.
And we did, we won.
Team yellow won the whole thing.
But just to aspect of,
I mean, between all the goofing off it,
like you're saying,
it was nice to have
conversations with people
where they valued our experience
and we were fascinated
with theirs and how
there's so much overlap
in where they're going and
what they're trying to build
and what we've already
built in a lot of ways
and just how we can kinda pay
it forward and help em out.
But also there's so much for
us to learn at the same time
because like the emphasis on shorts
is a totally new thing for YouTube.
Like grappling with the TikTok of it all.
And so everyone there has this spirit of
taking these tools and
what the algorithms,
how they behave,
being a student of
finding the intersection
between technology and self-expression
to reach an audience
and connect with them.
And I just found that very invigorating.
You know, it was cool to be
seen as people who were OGs
still relevant and valuable
to their experience.
I mean, Stevie was invited to
be one of the speakers there
talking about,
there were like four breakout
sessions that everybody could
go to and they happened twice.
So they ended up being like small groups.
So she came to Palm Springs
to talk about building a team,
which a lot of YouTubers
are interested in doing.
And it's a hard thing to figure out.
We weren't allowed to see her though.
I did see her.
How did you see her?
I walked up to her before her thing
and she immediately started laughing
because I was wearing
my glasses and my shorts
and my Palm Springs shirt.
And she was like, you really
look Palm Springs right now.
It's like, well, I'm having a ball.
And she was like, well
you gotta get outta here.
But I'm proud of what we have at Mythical
that it's not just about the two of us,
it's about our team.
And like Stevie represented him
being there and like lots of
people like even people who've been around
the block many times like Marquez saying,
he got a lot out of her session.
It's really cool.
And then they had this thing
called a magic mirror where you
could go up to it like a
mirror, mirror on the wall.
You ask em something about YouTube
and then you get a response.
And I don't know exactly how it worked,
but we were supposed to go in
and answer people's questions,
but we interacted with the mirror.
There was a guy,
I don't know if you knew this Rhett,
but there was a guy behind the mirror.
He was speaking through a speaker,
so it looked like the mirror was talking.
I know which guy it was too.
And then when we came out after
interacting with this guy,
like the YouTube person
was like, how did it go?
And I was like, honestly,
he was kind of an asshole.
And then you said, well
like he's a mirror.
He's just reflecting back
what he gets from you.
And I was like, oh, okay.
That's pretty fair.
So but he was a fan,
so like we were giving each other.
He knew who we were.
I was giving him a hard time.
He's a freaking mirror.
He was playing a character.
Well, one of the things too-
I didn't hurt his feelings,
I don't think.
No.
One of the things that
I'll say is obviously okay,
YouTube not perfect, right?
YouTube is a corporation,
obviously their goal as
part of Google is to grow,
make money, right?
But we have over the
course of this, our career,
gotten to know the people
who work at YouTube.
And when it comes to places
where you can make videos,
right, if you're just
a creator and you say,
okay well I can make videos on TikTok,
I can do things on Instagram,
I can do things on Facebook,
I can do things on
whatever the platform is.
And we do things everywhere.
We put content everywhere.
But there's one platform
in which you actually
have a connection with
the people who are making
these decisions and feel like,
oh, if I have a complaint
or if I have this idea or,
and obviously we're
privileged in that we've been
on the platform for a really long time
and we have a lot of
subscribers and we have a big,
and not everybody has that.
No, it's true of a
certain level of creator.
But what I ultimately
what I'm saying is that
they're not doing a
perfect job by any means,
but they're doing a much better job.
There isn't a close second.
There's no other platform that
is actually catering to and
listening to the creators and
understanding that the people
who make the content on their
platform are the heart and
soul of the platform.
And people get mad at
YouTube cuz they, you know,
people get mad at
everybody about everything.
That's just kind of the
way the world works now.
And so if you can get mad
at somebody about something,
you're gonna find a way to do it.
And you're gonna go on Twitter
and you're gonna say something.
But I'm just gonna say firsthand,
there's no summit for any other platform.
There's no place where you
actually know multiple people
who work for this
corporation and you know them
and you consider them, oh,
hey, so and so I've seen you
multiple times at multiple events.
I kind of consider you a friend.
Like they are doing a good
job of connecting with and
listening to the people who
are the heart and soul of their
platform and I gotta hand it to 'em.
I mean that's why if we can
make it to events like that,
we're going to,
a lot of times we can't
because of our schedule,
but I think it's because
you get this sense
that first of all I'm gonna
get to meet other people
who I can relate to who do what we do.
We're gonna learn things,
we're gonna make important connections,
but we're also gonna think, well, okay,
well what's coming down the line now?
Like what is important
to YouTube right now
and how does that make us better
creators on this platform?
And how do we do a better job
of connecting with our fans
and continuing to run a healthy business?
There's not many opportunities
like that outside that.
Yeah and it rejuvenated
my energy to continue
to pay it forward to other
creators and you know,
with our Mythical Creator
Accelerator where we're literally
investing money into other
creator's businesses to help them
accelerate their building their own brand,
not in the same way that we did,
but in their own,
to build their own version of
what we've built with Mythical
is an exciting aspect of what
we're literally investing in.
And so it's rewarding to
have those conversations
with other creators and know that they,
that it can be a mutually
beneficial relationship
and there's a lot more potential there.
My one feedback for YouTube though,
at a certain time it
got a little corporate
when they were like we're all eating lunch
and they're like you gotta
get to the next session,
the next like programming session.
But everybody said the
content is about to start
and then you start walking
and somebody else would say,
the content is this way.
It felt weird.
It's like don't use the
word content so much.
It's like it's a session.
The stuff.
It's the stuff is this way.
The session, the program
is about to begin.
The thing you're looking for is this way.
The content is about to start.
It's like, hey, you know that word,
you're stretching it too thin YouTube.
Okay.
Work on it.
Good feedback.
You're getting a little too,
what's it called bubbleized here.
One thing that I will say,
there's always a little
bit of swag at these events
and there's usually a piece of clothing.
And I think this year I
got my favorite one ever,
I brought it.
Oh, show it to me.
Dr. Emily was not there.
She did not bring swag.
Oh, he's off.
He's trying to get off camera.
He is gonna make a reveal.
There it is.
Hello, I'm very comfortable in my robe.
Oh, what's that you say?
What's my YouTube channel?
Good Mythical Morning.
Can you read that?
Jenna you're exactly right.
She said you look like
you're wearing a circus tent.
I love this.
It's a terry cloth robe that you,
I mean put a pole in
the middle of it, man.
So are you telling me that-
You could have said there already is one.
Well, here's the thing,
literally a week before the
Creator Summit I was on Amazon.
I go on Amazon sometimes
and other websites.
I'm not just exclusive to Amazon.
I like that Prime shipping though.
Jeffrey Bezos.
Looking for robes.
I got a robe.
I know, but I don't.
That one.
And now I got this one.
And here's the thing about this robe
is that it's not technically reversible,
but it might as well be.
Yeah.
It's like you're wearing a
different color circus tent.
No, I only do this between December,
December 18th, my wife's
birthday and January 1st
I'm gonna wear this every day.
You're a candy cane.
Yeah, I'm a candy cane man.
Don't encourage him.
I mean, look at that.
I'm the most relaxed
Santa there's ever been.
I'm like-
We had fun didn't we Rhett?
Oh, and we got massages.
We didn't give each other massages.
You didn't make that joke
when we showed up at the massage parlor.
I was just say parlor,
the spa at the same time.
But that was nice.
Thanks.
That was nice.
Glad you added that.
Yeah, well I'm just saying
I saw myself in this robe.
This podcast is over,
don't start talking about massages.
Oh no, I'm just saying that like it was,
I hadn't had one of those in years.
We gotta close this thing down.
Yup, so we have fun.
It's my wreck.
Yeah. Baby wreck baby 1, 2, 3, 4.
If you're into hip hop like I am,
then you already know about this.
I don't need to tell you,
but I just wanna validate what
you already know to be true
is the new JID album, The
Forever Story is really good.
So if you haven't listened to the album,
you should.
And if you have,
you should watch his Tiny Desk concert,
that NPR series.
It's nice.
He's three nices from Link Neil.
All right.
What are we doing next week?
Do we know?
We do know we wrote it down,
but I don't know at
this moment what it is.
Scares us most.
Oh, we're gonna be talking
about what scares us the most
because it's October and that's the month
where you gotta be real scared of things.
We're gonna take your call ins.
We're prepping 'em up.
What?
Oh that's the week after,
maybe you can still call in.
Nice, that's what we got.
So what scares us most is next week.
Yeah.
Not what scares you the most.
And then what and then after that
is things that have scared you the most.
It's gonna be like,
is the following week things that you
It's tattoo too
redundant? No,
cuz it's people talking about
like paranormal, spooky,
supernatural, crazy
that's happened to you.
We shouldn't have these
programmatic conversations within
the podcast,
but I was just trying to
make it a legitimate teaser.
Yeah, but what is it, what
is our number 188earpodone.
And don't forget to talk about
Ear Biscuits on the internet
with hashtag Ear Biscuits
because we will find you
And you know what, have a baby.
I don't give a shit.
Hello Rhett and Link.
I was just listening to your
latest Ear Biscuits release
and I really wanna thank you two
for talking about local elections.
You started to talk about the possibility
of being a mayor of a town.
I have served on my
small town city council
and I am currently running to be
in my state's legislature in the
Georgia State House of Representatives.
You are very correct in
saying that these hyper local
elections are incredibly
important if you really want to
start affecting change literally
right outside your own front door.
It's not about being President
of the United States,
it's about being on those
groups of people that help make
decisions about how your city is developed
and planned and run.
You are very correct about
if you're doing it right,
it is an act of service.
That's why I like to describe
myself as a public servant
rather than a politician.
I'm a public servant first
and a politician second.
So I will see you guys at Smith Ethicon.
Thanks for all you.
Good Mythical greetings to you.
My name is Matt out of Alabama
and I just thought you guys
should know that I have a
recurring dream where I travel to
your studio on a sweepstakes
of some kind and I desperately
try to convince one of you or
Stevie to give me a job in HR
for some reason.
To be clear,
I love my job and I don't think
I would take another offer,
but that's a dream I have and I apologize.
Hey, Rhett and Link.
This is Paige from Detroit, Michigan
and I just wanted to let
you guys know that my dog
with anxiety loves to listen to you guys.
I mean I love to listen to you guys too,
but she loves to listen to
you guys while I'm gone.
It helps her so much.
She just sits on the couch and
curls up and listens to you
guys while I'm gone.
So just let everybody know
that your podcasts are for dogs too.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
We love you.
Bye.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episodes of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left
and don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.